you've got a couple of charts here for
us let's start first with uh the
commodities index we were just talking
about wheat oil uh
nickels in there um a whole bunch of
different stuff that uh just seems to be
going up into the moon what is your read
on this like plus 30 is absurd yeah year
to date and so
um you know for for the 2010s we had a
pretty prolonged period of uh
disinflationary commodity trends um kind
of riding on the wave of previous capex
cycles and so you know following the
coveted stimulus and that kind of demand
shock that we gave to marcus we started
to see rising inflation right inflation
was at 40 year highs in november when
powell said all right we got to start to
get this in check
and recently um and this is something
that you know no one really could have
foreseen i i guess maybe some
geopolitical experts but uh this this
hot war that's occurring um really the
economic war that's occurring with all
the nation states and russia is just
throwing napalm on this inflation crisis
um i gotta i got a note here eleven
percent of the global oil supply
seventeen percent of global net gas
eleven percent uh of global wheat and
ten percent of industrial minerals are
produced in russia
um so if essentially everyone's black
mark uh just saying you know we don't
want your commodities uh and and just
kind of holding them hostage and i think
evidently they'll they'll work with
china but there's no way to just snap
your fingers and make up that demand in
global markets and so
what's the result simple supply and
demand prices are soaring uh and and
there's pretty wide implications for
that
when you look at the bond market
obviously that has a huge impact uh as
well as this all plays out we've seen
incredible volatility to the upside to
start the year uh similar read on this
as well
yeah so i mean if you think about a
fixed income product right you're
sitting and you're getting a fixed
payment in fiat currency okay and so uh
if you're if your goal as a capital
allocator is to maintain or grow your
purchasing power you know bonds that pay
a coupon that's above inflation is a
good deal you get you get a payment and
not only uh you you grow your purchasing
power nominal terms but in real terms um
but if we say have inflation at eight
percent and i think these next readings
with these commodity markets going
parabolic these next readings are going
to accelerate in terms of cpi and so
you're sitting on a fixed income product
what do you do well you dump it you sell
it um so we're seeing massive volatility
in the most liquid markets in the world
like people think of equities as kind of
the driver but really behind the scenes
these fixed income markets these credit
markets uh really kind of set said
everything else and so we're seeing just
massive volatility in in credit markets
we're almost surpassing uh the kind of
covet crisis and so uh there's trouble
uh and the plumbing is uh is you know
saying there's there's there's something
wrong uh in these in these global
markets and i expect volatility to
actually increase
got it and then when we start to look at
uh the junk in corporate debt that seems
to be in a free fall uh pretty
aggressively you know explain why that's
happening
yeah so covered this on the past couple
of your shows uh previous months and a
lot of people reach out and be like you
know aren't you kind of interested in
bitcoin why the hell are you covering
junk debt like who cares uh and the
reality is um you know behind the scenes
there's pretty big implications uh if
these things are selling off so the
principal value of bonds is inverse to
the yield so when these things are
selling off right because inflation's
running hot you own fixed income you
sell it because it's not a good deal
anymore it's not a good bang for your
buck
uh well what happens is the yields rise
and so what this means and we cover this
a little bit later is not only is kind
of liquidity draining out of these fixed
income markets but also the financing
costs for these corporates is rising in
tandem so so not only are these fixed
income investors delivering they're
they're selling they're getting these
off their books uh but also you see
financing costs really rising across the
board for corporates and so we haven't
even really seen that come into play yet
but this isn't just a kind of a
corporate debt or investment you know
junk or investment grade debt corporate
thing this is just basically all fixed
income products because again inflation
is is so rampant and so eventually and i
think what hasn't been priced into
markets yet unfortunately uh is that
these inflation risks and these kind of
the credit sell-off eventually leads to
liquidity liquidity and solvency risk uh
in fixed income markets as no one can
get can get cheap financing in a
historically over-embedded economy uh
and so you know there there's uh these
markets are spelling trouble
got it and so when you start to look at
uh things like the corporate credit
spreads uh it seems that uh the drop in
the s p 500 being inversely correlated
uh to uh to these corporate spreads um
you've also overlaid here the vix on top
of it how do you kind of navigate the
the complexity that's involved with the
relationship between these types of uh
measurements or assets
yeah so you know why look at these at
all what what can they tell you and so i
overlaid corporate credit spreads which
are essentially it's it's the yield on
top of the treasury yield so the
treasury market is that kind of
risk-free global fixed income market uh
it's really still thought of um as a
global safe haven despite you know a lot
of people saying i would never own bonds
it still is that risk-free rate in the
global economic system so we see this
corporate credit spread meaning uh when
this is going up the corporate credit
spread it means that financing costs for
corporates
and this is uh triple b corporates uh is
is rising farther than the actual that
treasury yield and so that means that
it's harder to get financing for these
companies and so overlaying that with
the vix you can see there's a pretty
tight relationship um obviously there's
a lot of volatility in the vix which is
a volatility index itself but there's a
pretty you know pretty correlated
relationship between these two things
and i highlighted whenever both of those
metrics or indicators are rising i
highlighted what happens to the s p 500
what happens to equities so equity
market volatility explodes um and it's
more so kind of a function of this the
lack of liquidity and credit markets
which is reflected in the credit spreads
and what happens the equity indices dump
and so you know there's a lot of things
happening behind the scenes here but
recently you know with i think the
nasdaq is 20 off the highs i'm not sure
what the dow or s p is but uh
really the credit markets we're starting
to say there's a problem back in
november and now with all of this
inflation happening and the kind of
madness in the commodity markets uh you
know the equity equity markets are are
teetering i think that's what's going on
got it and so when you start to look at
things like the 10-year
yield curve
how much are these still like a clean
signal uh for inflation expectations and
and other metrics versus are these
becoming distorted by uh the complexity
of the market
yeah so uh here we have the ten year and
the 2-year yield curve so subtract the
2-year yield from the 10-year yield
and you get what most people refer to or
you know credit traders refer to as the
yield curve and basically this
this indicator this metric has pre-dated
when when it inverts when it goes below
zero uh it's called a yield curve
inversion when it's gone below zero it's
predated every single recession since
the 1960s um and and even before that i
just missed one in the sixties uh it was
a false signal um because why you have
to if you think about how the credit
system works uh most creditors lenders
in the financial system they borrow
short so like banks they'll borrow short
and lend long they'll take on short
dated liabilities uh and acquire
elongated assets
um
you know like they'll borrow from the
fed for you know a year or whatever it
is and land for ten or two inland for
ten um so when this yield curve inverts
when you when you can actually get a
higher yield uh by holding a two-year
treasury note than a ten-year treasury
note there's problems because
traditionally that yield curve kind of
you'll get a higher yield the farther
you go out in duration so when this
inverts there's pretty big liquidity
problems in the market and so recently
it hasn't inverted but we're seeing a
pretty massive uh flattening of this
curve and it looks like uh if we kind of
just focus on the trend
it looks like an inversion is coming
and so and this is the crazy thing is uh
whenever these yield curve inversions
start to happen traditionally we've seen
the fed start to loosen financial
conditions but now we're sitting here
with raging inflation uh and a yield
curve contr a yield curve inversion
potentially coming and the fed funds
rate is still at zero uh so truly
historic and honestly the fed is
completely trapped in what they can do
uh and i you know i would not want to be
jerome powell in this situation hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time